I like I like the way that you said
entering into music there's a terrible
thing that's been happening probably for
the last 20 years or so and it's called
the music business and music isn't
really business its work and you gotta
pay you gotta you know by your guitar or
go into the studio so there is a
business side but when people say I'm
going into the music business it's not
it's about expression it's about
creativity you don't you don't join
music in my mind to make money you join
it because it's in you it's in your
blood stream so if you want to be Justin
Timberlake go for it if you want to be
somebody else go for us but it's usually
very hard just got to believe in
yourself work hard I've no advice I mean
I did everything the right and wrong way
but you know you make it up as you go
along but it has to be in your
bloodstream and it's not a job it's a
way of life